Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will be
my new Justice League Snyder cut deleted scenes
video Zack Snyder just had a big Snydercon and
revealed a bunch more deleted scenes and extra
footage that didn't make it into the theatrical
version or at least the final version of the
Justice League Snyder cut it was really more
of a home video release but it has screened in
some theaters since then if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos if they reveal more deleted scenes like
Ben Affleck was talking about his version of
the Batman movie I might also do a separate video
about that too at some point usually when he does
these Snyder cons he'll reveal like really cool
lore details and things that didn't make it into
the Final Cut one of the biggest reveals that he
made at this latest snydercon this past weekend
was that during all the flashbacks the lore scenes
when they would have been showing the gods going
to war with Darkseid telling more of this ancient
history on Earth from 10 000 years ago and longer
and as part of that they were going to explain
that Wonder Woman's biological father Zeus Greek
god of lightning also kind of like the god of gods
or at least that Greek pantheon of gods would have
also secretly been a crypto living on Earth for
tens of thousands of years a Kryptonian so that
Wonder Woman's powers anyway you could sort of see
where that's going you know because you know the
whole thing of like whether or not magic and the
Gods you know there's a version where like okay
that's cool I guess but like you know there's also
the more sort of scientific kind of you know you
have like a mythology built up of like why where
do gods come from like what is that about you know
Jerry's was the one that caused the Scout ship to
crash yeah and be in the ice what yeah yeah yeah
he killed his crew well you can't just throw that
out there yeah so instead of saying that he was
an actual Celestial God like the Wonder Woman
Comics they would have said that all of his
powers evolve the same way that Superman's powers
work because of his Kryptonian DNA just living in
Earth's system in the soul system like heat vision
flight super strength super speed super hearing
super senses just in general intangentially as
a result because this was all for the purpose of
changing Wonder Woman's backstory Wonder Woman
would have been half Kryptonian kind of like
Superboy and that was going to be Zack Snyder's
way of saying that's where her powers came from
and why she was so similar to Superman why their
powers were similar in some aspects here's the
thing about that like immediately people will
think wait a minute Superman can't generate
lightning from his body we've never seen any
crypto that I can remember from the comics that
have that power either Zack Snyder didn't really
clarify this particular point but I think the idea
is that because Zeus passed all of his abilities
to Wonder Woman through his DNA like literally
through his DNA to his child they would have just
explained that in the Snyder verse of continuity
like in his Universe of movies that was just one
of the powers that some kryptonians could develop
naturally given enough time like the powers that
Zeus had biologically evolved slightly differently
from Superman's powers because they're different
people even though it's not quite that way in the
comics in the comics up to this point pretty much
all kryptonians no matter which family they come
from no matter how young or old they are tend to
have the exact same powers like Zod and Superman
for instance any other Kryptonian that came to
Earth all would have exactly the same powers
and it sounds like Zack Snyder just planned for
that to be different he went on to say the idea
was Zeus's backstory like his secret history is
that twenty thousand years ago ten thousand years
before this dark side War during krypton's Age of
expansion when jorel was teaching Superman their
people's history in the Man of Steel movie Zeus
had been one of the Kryptonian explorers his ship
in the other kryptonians that were part of his
crew crashed in the Arctic on Earth long ago in
an era of expansion I'll race spread out through
the Stars seeking new worlds to settle upon the
Scout ship was one of thousands launched into the
void in Zeus's ship would have been the Kryptonian
ship that Superman found in the Man of Steel
movie and to explain the other dead kryptonians
Superman found like the other bodies they had
initially planned on saying that it was Aries
who caused that war between the gods but it was
really between the kryptonians crew members had
they actually wound up doing things that way the
story that hapalto would have told to Young Wonder
Woman about the war between the gods of their
backstory would have obviously been a lie but
in order for the timeline to work they would have
had to explain that Aries didn't kill the other
Kryptonian crew members until after the dark side
War so they were on planet Earth for a long time
because they said the Kryptonian ship was over 20
000 years old themiskirans are born and then after
the dark side War Ares then Rebels against the
other kryptonians so to speak or in this version
they would have been kryptonians then Zeus dies
and Aries goes into hiding that would have also
have meant that it was Kryptonian technology that
Zeus used to create Themiscyra and cloak it from
the rest of the world and basically meant that
all the themiscyrans would have been low-level
kryptonians in some way okay getting to the Game
of Thrones of it all like you're kind of doing the
math in your head like wait a minute hippolyta
was already Kryptonian all kryptonians on Earth
descended from Zeus I'm assuming this meant that
hippolyta would have been one of the subsequent
daughters from one of Zeus's other many offspring
remember he's 20,000 years old so he probably has
a lot of children over these years including
the idea that all the themiscyrans had part of
his DNA meaning that Zack Snyder was planning on
going full Game of Thrones Targaryen with people
marrying within their bloodline making all those
Game of Thrones jokes Zack Snyder said that when
they were developing this the studio made them
take it out of the movie because they hated the
idea of Wonder Woman as a Kryptonian which was a
huge change from the comics obviously he explained
his reasoning for wanting to make Wonder Woman a
Kryptonian secretly was to say that there were no
actual Gods who existed like there were no Gods
just Ultra powerful evolved beings in the way Q
from Star Trek isn't meant to be a God He just
seems like one the Q Continuum or just a race
of Highly evolved beings with god-like powers I'm
not a big fan of the idea of making Wonder Woman a
Kryptonian so I am glad they cut that out of the
movie based on the other stuff that Zack Snyder
said at his Justice League Snyder cut panel had
he gotten to make Justice League two in Justice
League three all the other spin-offs that they had
planned at the time they would have covered more
of that alternate Zeus Kryptonian backstory
in some of the other spin-offs by the end of
Justice League three but the idea is they didn't
write the first Wonder Woman movie till after they
gotten the notes from the studio to get rid
of that Zeus backstory changes with all the
Kryptonian stuff Zack Snyder was heavily involved
in the making of that first Wonder Woman movie if
you didn't realize he even has a cameo during it
that's why the visual Style just like the tone
of that Wonder Woman movie seems very similar to
the other Snyder verse movies he largely already
parted with the studio by the time Wonder Woman
1984 came around so he wasn't really involved
with Wonder Woman 1984 which is why it seems so
different but when they started making that first
Wonder Woman movie they had already changed Zeus's
backstory to be more comic book accurate so when
hapalita is telling the younger Wonder Woman the
backstory of the gods they didn't have to make
any changes to that floor it was always like that
for that particular movie it sounds like all the
Zeus Kryptonian stuff had started when they were
first developing the Justice League movie in the
Justice League sequels while they were still in
the middle of working on Batman v Superman the
way that Zack Snyder explained is that because
of the way the studio contracted with him to
develop their Justice League connected movies
that started before he started making Batman be
Superman like they were making Batman v Superman
with the expressed idea that they were going to
be making all these Justice League sequels so
when they were making Batman v Superman they
began creating this larger mythology that they'd
cover through all the Justice League movies and
the other spin-offs behind all these characters
like including Darkseid the anti-life equation
there's a lot of untold story like Zack Snyder
always hints about stuff like oh we had a lot
of ideas about what we're going to do with the
anti-life equation but because it was so much
World building and mythology that they had
developed at the time so many ideas it would
have taken them a bunch of spin-offs to also cover
all these backstories he's already revealed with
the majority of the Justice League 2 and Justice
League 3 movies would have been released all the
stories in the concept art I did a giant video for
that a little while ago so I had a link for that
at the end of this and down in the description
below because it gets really crazy like there's
some controversial stuff that he wanted to
get into particularly the whole Batman Lois
Lane storyline the other really interesting thing
that Zack Snyder said as part of this completely
separately is part of Batman's backstory with
the dead Nightwing Robin his backstory with
the Jared Leto Joker is that he didn't want to
reveal too much of what happened between them
because it was a chance that he could tell that
story in the future so everybody naturally was
like wait a minute what does that mean make it
that what you will as far as I know James Gunn
has no plans to do any kind of elseworld stories
with Zack Snyder at least right now that could
always change but the idea is that if Zack Snyder
ever did continue any of his story threads in any
kind of medium like if he did a comic book or
really anything based on the upcoming plan for
how all the DC movies connect they treat all the
Snyder of her story as an else World story right
now The Flash movie doing a version of Flashpoint
with the Snyder vs characters in Michael Keaton's
Batman is meant to sort of Usher are in the new
era of DC movies and they're explaining because
of that Flashpoint twist that's why everything
changes I'm sure there's going to be a ton of
questions about the new continuity how everything
works don't worry as we start getting more footage
for The Flash movie of course I'll do more videos
for that let me know what you think about that
radically different Zeus backstory though about
making him a Kryptonian I might do a separate
video for Ben Affleck's Batman movie he also was
at the snydercon talking about his version of the
Batman movie Deathstroke was going to be the
villain and he revealed some of what's going
on with the villains and what his plans for that
movie were going to be Guardians of the Galaxy 3
is also coming out this week be sure to go see it
when you have a chance my full post credit scene
video my full Easter eggs and breakdown videos
will start posting later this week after the
movie comes out there's a lot of stuff that
we have to talk about also later this week
is Star Wars day they're releasing the new Star
Wars Visions episodes I'll try to do an episode
video for all those there might be some more cool
trailers and stuff later this week we might get a
new Loki season 2 trailer pretty soon too everyone
click here to learn about Star Wars plans for calc
in live action and click here for my new Flash
movie trailer with a bunch more Ben Affleck
Batman thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!